so also vielen dank für die einleitung
jörg und danke auch das mich eingeladen
hast du bist ja an mich herangetreten
mit der frage kannst du was über das
böse im film machen
da hat sich für mich natürlich als
erstes gleich die frage gestellt was ist
eigentlich die begriffsbestimmung dessen
was im das böse im film eigentlich sein
kann ist ja naheliegend und erst mal
wenn man von der guten bedeutung ausgeht
ich weiß nicht ob er gestern schon etwas
dazu gesagt worden ist diese zwei
verschiedenen primär bedeutungen die da
vorherrschen oder die reben stehen
einmal dass morales schlechte
verwerfliche und auf der anderen seite
eher im sinne von schlecht schlimm und
übel das problem dass sich dadurch für
uns im film ergibt es das eigentlich das
böse im film alles sein kann
grund dafür ist dass literatur allem
allgemeinen als gegen diskurs aufgefasst
wird was auch michelle foucault als
begrifflichkeit gefasst hat er schreibt
während des ganzen neunzehnten
jahrhunderts und bis in unsere zeit hat
die literatur nun aber nur in ihrer
autonomie existiert von jeder anderen
sprache durch einen tiefen einschnitt
nur sich losgelöst indem sie eine art
gegen diskurs bildete seiner warnung hat
dementsprechend von poetischer konter
diskursive tät gesprochen und er führt
aus dass für poetische und das heißt
generell literarische texte
grundsätzlich in einem
spannungsverhältnis zu diskursiv
organisiertem wissen also zuordnung des
diskurses sieht als freiraum neben und
außerhalb von macht des positiven und
das bedeutet eben dass literatur
generell gesprochen also texte
fiktionale texte wozu eben auch film
gehört wir sprechen hier eben vom
erweiterten text begriff dass filme eben
auch als texte gelten können
weil eben die in ihrer funktionalität
losgelöst sind eben von normalen
diskursen und das hat eben zur folge
dass es böse im film eigentlich alles
sein kann
da habe ich jetzt auch mal so ein paar
beispiele mitgebracht diese
verschiedenen gruppierungen ganz
klassisch natürlich übernatürliche wesen
der eine kategorie von dem bösen was man
im film so kennt der klassiker die
teufels figur wie hier im
beispiel die legende von 1985 aber
mittlerweile gibt es natürlich auch
teufels figuren die viel stärker an der
alltagswelt orientiert sind
das heißt mittlerweile ist auch schon
ein bisschen älter aber al pacino zum
beispiel in im auftrag des teufels in
dem er als das personifizierte böse
auftritt aber eben als anwalt eine
weitere kategorie eben in dem bereich
übernatürliche wesen wären so was wie
böse hexen und magier die sauren in der
filmtrilogie der herr der ringe oder
auch monster wie zum beispiel koh zähler
der bisher auch schon in 29 japanischen
und amerikanischen filmen seit 1954
aufgetreten ist das ist natürlich nicht
alles es gibt natürlich auch jede menge
menschliche charaktere die das böse
verkörpern können im film das klassische
wäre ja natürlich der schurke oder das
prinzip des willen des bösewichts im
western zum beispiel liefern cleef in
zwölf uhr mittags falls man ihn kennt
natürlich auch viele andere die so
funktionieren das sind oft männliche
figuren aber natürlich auch frauen
können typischerweise das böse
personifizieren
man kennt so zb die böse stiefmutter mit
charlize theron in essen white and the
huntsman oder auch unter anderem in
disney filmen wie zum beispiel ursula in
ariel
da werden eben auch diese kontrast
figuren immer eingeführt dann gibt es
eine weitere kategorie die ich gerne das
pervertierte böse nennen würde
das sind eigentlich positiv konnotierte
figuren die aber dann negative züge
annehmen dann wird zum beispiel denken
an indem eben der clown zum
personifizierten bösen wird oder in der
exorzist wo auch ein kind zum bösen
werden kann
aber nicht nur auf dieser personalen
ebene wirklich als figur sondern auch im
bereich natur kann das böse im film
auftreten wenn man sowas hat wie wohl
keine wo es eben um naturkatastrophen
geht die auch böse züge annehmen können
oft handelt sich dann um so eine
anthropomorphe sierung der natur die
ihnen dadurch auch diese bösen züge
annehmen kann
andere beispiele werden 2012 oder auch
so was wie
auch break wo eben ein virus dann auch
dieses böse andere personifiziert weiter
auch auf der natur ebene so was die
anaconda oder der weiße hai klassiker
das eben auch tiere zum bösen werden
können im film also wo man eben auch
sagt dass es unwillentlich aber trotzdem
im film dargestellt als dieses böse
andere weiterhin so was wie räume wie
gegenstände also auch unbelebte objekte
können im film zum bösen werden die tu
mantel dieses gesellschaftsspiel das
eben auch diese bösen strukturen dann
hat und dadurch eben auch böse dinge
auslöst oder zum beispiel mit kiefer
sutherland der eben durch spiegel in so
eine andere welt geleitet wird die eben
da auch so eine anthroposophie sierung
erfahren auch räume können böse
strukturen annehmen in filmen wie jetzt
das geisterschloss so ganz klassisch
edel so dieser negativ konnotierte raum
oder sowas wie zimmer 14 08 was eben
auch so an sich zu einem richtig
belebten raum wird in dem böse dinge
passieren weil es eben dieser raum ist
bisschen breiter gesprochen wenn wir
auch auf gesellschaftliche strukturen
das ganze übertragen in disziplinen zum
beispiel ganz klassisch gilt die
gesellschaft als das böse in diesem in
diesen filmen oder auch texten die
tribute zum paar von kampagnen zum
beispiel da geht es eben darum dass die
gesellschaft an sich die kinder dazu
zwingt sich gegenseitig in einer arena
umzubringen
hier personifiziert durch den
präsidenten aber da braucht man gar
nicht mal so weit gehen weil selbst bei
uns im tatort geht es eben oft um diese
sozialen strukturen die eben böse folgen
haben und das böse sich daraus
entwickelt als man kann im film sagen
dass jegliche form der jegliches ding
jegliches ereignis eigentlich zum bösen
werden kann
die frage eben was die essenz des bösen
im film ist oder eine gewisse wesenheit
bringt uns im film eigentlich überhaupt
gar nicht weiter was mir als wesentlich
erscheint es dass es um die ästhetische
funktion geht welche funktion hat das
böse im film und da lehne ich mich so
ein bisschen an philipp k
definition an was er geschrieben hat in
dem es oft über von 2006 die die auf ivo
ist ein fertiges konzept also hier in
der narrativen erzählkunst hier ist es
allgemein gesprochen eben auf klassische
diskurse aber das ist eben genauso
übertragbar im film dass es um die rolle
geht die das böse im film einnehmen ein
ende was ich eben er so auf diese
funktionale ebene geben würde also die
funktion die das böse im film spielt und
jetzt ist die frage wie kann man
eigentlich das böse im film über diese
funktionalität erfassen
dazu habe ich ein kommunikationsmodell
also ein ganz einfaches klassisches
kommunikationsmodell nach ansgar nünning
und vera nünning adaptiert das ist
ursprünglich eben ein literarisches
kommunikationsmodell was ich nur ganz
kurz vor allem nicht filmwissenschaftler
vielleicht kurz vorstellen möchte sein
filmisches kommunikationsmodell
adaptiert wesentlich ist eben dass wir
diese ganzen verschiedenen ebenen haben
auf denen diese funktionen auftreten
können wie das böse haben kann
das wäre eben einmal in diesem
kommunikationsmodell auf der senderseite
dass wir ein produktionsteam haben also
drehbuchautor regisseur das ganze
produktionsteam kameramann und so weiter
auch schauspieler ganz wichtig die eine
message haben und es wäre eben das film
narrativ also die erzählung die im film
vonstatten geht und die wird übertragen
durch ein medium das wäre eben das führt
der film mit seinen verschiedenen codes
also visuelle und ästhetische kurz da
gehört alles dazu vom kostüm bis zum
schauspieler körper von den bildaufbau
geräusche musik diese ganzen sachen und
gerade film spezifisch relevant so was
die kameraperspektive montage schnitt
bildbearbeitung voice overs diese ganzen
sachen die eben extra im film relevant
werden
wichtig auch empfehlen das war sehr
starke realität effekte hergestellt
werden können
weil eben dass durch diese mimetischen
darstellung der wirklichkeit also
wirklich die nachahmung der wirklichkeit
auch wenn das jetzt vielleicht
fiktionale oder fiktive welten sind
haben sie immer ein gewisses ergebnisse
ähnlichkeit zu unserer welt und dadurch
wird eben in dieser abbildung dieser
realität effektiven erzeugt und diese
botschaft wird eben empfänger also den
rezipienten oder zuschauer gesendet der
eben sich den film anschaut wichtig eben
dass der empfänger und der sender dass
die zusammen eben über einen code
miteinander verbunden sind klassisch so
ganz allgemein gesprochen sprache ist
natürlich sinnvoll wenn ich mir einen
film anschaut dass ich die sprache
verstehe aber gerade im film geht es
darum dass man auch die verschiedenen
filmischen coach kennt also um eben auch
filme dann lesen zu können
und als letzter punkt die historischen
kontexte die eben natürlich einfluss
haben auf die botschaft also politische
soziale ökonomische implikationen des
ganzen kulturellen rahmens in denen der
film gemacht wird und rezipiert wird und
die ästhetischen funktionen eben des
bösen können auf da all diesen ebenen
bezugspunkte haben und das ziel ist
jetzt in den nächsten 20 minuten oder so
dass sich diese einzelnen felder also
auch ein bisschen gruppiert vorstellen
um eben dieses panorama dieser ganzen
funktionalen möglichkeiten aufzuzeigen
ich habe mich da jetzt vor allem
beschränkt auf den anglo amerikanischen
und europäischen film
weil das eben auch das was man hier so
so kennt und was ihm womit man oft
konfrontiert wird so auf der ebene der
botschaft
neben den filmen narrativ der erzählung
das ist eben wichtig dass sich
eigentlich vier einflussfaktoren auf
da sind die ihnen diese diese handlung
funktionalität beeinflussen
das ist einmal der zeitpunkt wann das
böse im narrativ auftritt also und wird
sich eben da dann auch entwickelt also
sowas ist es böse schon von anfang an da
oder kommt drittes er später auf wird es
am ende in einem happy end aufgelöst und
zerstört so dass eine innere ordnung der
gesellschaft
wieder wieder besteht oder bleibt es
böse eigentlich bis zum ende noch
bestehen ja also wird es am ende
eigentlich nicht zerstört der zweite
punkt wäre eben der point of view
wer konstruiert eigentlich wen im film
als das böse und es dritter punkt die
was ebenfalls schon hatten welche form
des bilden gibt es eigentlich also was
sie schon genannt hat dass es eben
personen oder nicht personen sein können
objekte natur und so weiter und als
vierten punkt eben dass es auch eine
sehr stark graduelle abstufung des bösen
gibt also angefangen einmal vom absolut
bösen was im film natürlich auftreten
kann wenn man jetzt so was hat wie harry
potter und lord voldemort wo eben als
keine entwicklungspotenziale dieser
figuren eigentlich gibt es ist so das
unmotivierte böse das einfach böse ist
was böse ist und es braucht auch keine
begründung dass es böse ist ein bisschen
abgestuft wie dieses absolut böse hätten
wir so was wie darth vader in star wars
das ist zwar auch eine figur die
grundsätzlich mal als absolut böse
gelten kann
aber da ist diese figuren entwicklung am
ende da weil am ende bringt er ja dann
parat um und wird eben dann zum guten am
ende wieder wieder zurückgeholt
sozusagen also da ist diese in der
figuren in der entwicklungsdynamik eben
überhaupt erst möglich eben diesen
diesen figuren zum beispiel
natürlich gibt's dann auch gewisse
mischformen des bösen also gerade in
neueren filmen zeigt sich eben da so
eine tendenz zu seiner multi dimensional
i tät in denen es eben kein entweder
oder bei den figuren gibt sondern ein
sowohl als auch
aktuelles beispiel wäre die serie game
of thrones wo im endeffekt jeder der
charaktere beides ist und irgendwie
dreck am stecken hat auch wenn die guten
charaktere können eben da zum bösen
werden und das ziel dabei ist natürlich
so ein bisschen eine realistischere
darstellung des bösen im bezug auf die
menschliche psyche und auch auf deren
abhängigkeit von den gesellschaftlichen
strukturen aufzuzeigen noch ein bisschen
schwächer wäre so diese idee des anti
helden oder der anti helden noch ein
bisschen
meister gefasst so dieser bergbau oder
batgirl typus das wären ebenso
charaktere die eigentlich helden sind
aber eine gewisse moralische schwäche
aufweisen und eben böse dinge tun und es
gehört auch so ein bisschen zu ihrer
wesenheit und ihrem charakter
aber irgendwie sind sie ja dann doch
liebenswert und oft so am ende kommen
sie kommt auch zu seiner moralischen
läuterung wo sie dann zum richtigen
helden mutieren können aber dieses anti
bleibt eigentlich immer noch so ein
bisschen bestehen wenn man jetzt zum
beispiel denkt an sowas wie hancock als
den klassischen anti superhelden der
dann auch so weil er halt oft betrunken
ist und dann auch so ein bisschen ja
dieses bad boy image hat dass er eben
auch gesetzlose dinge tut und eben damit
seiner superkraft ich überhaupt gar
nicht richtig umgehen kann und als
letzten punkt gäbe es dann noch so was
wie die dass unschuldige unfreiwillige
oder situative böse wie ich das nennen
würde das mehr ein handlungsorientierter
eine handlungsorientierte interpretation
ist wo es eben ein bisschen von diesem
statischen begriff des bösen weg geht
haben es geht darum dass eben handlungen
kontextabhängig böse sein können eben
auch bei figuren die eigentlich gut sind
ja also da ist es eben auch so dass es
eben situativ wichtig wird das ist auch
sehr oft so in kinderfilmen in denen
eben die helden was tun und dann aber
vielleicht einen einen fehltritt begehen
und am ende dann auch wieder geläutet
aus der ganzen sache raus gehen und
einen sich dass es ein einsicht haben
dass es ein fehlverhalten war und ist
eben eine didaktische botschaft am ende
hat also weil man denkt an zum beispiel
die eiskönigin von disney das wäre dann
eine klassische klassisches beispiel
dafür genre theoretisch ist es böse also
auch nicht eingrenzbar also sowas wie
horrorfilme ist blätter filme krimi
thriller explorations films das sind
alles filme die das böse der performativ
in den vordergrund stellt aber das ist
eben nur ein teil der wahrheit weil das
böse im film eben auch in kinder- und
jugendfilm in der komödie auftreten kann
und eben da thematisch werden kann das
böse in film ist also generell genre
unspezifisch und diese vier punkte die
ich eben schon genannt habe
also erstens diese ganzen arten des
bösen dann seine entwicklung dann die
perspektive auf das böse wer das böse
eben konstruiert und dieser grad diese
graduelle abstufung des bösen die
definieren eigentlich die handlungs
funktionalität des bösen also welche
funktion übernimmt das böse dann in der
handlung und da gibt es eben zwei
wesentliche funktionen auf der plot
ebene
das eine wäre eben dass dieses böse
einen antagonismus von außen her stellt
also einen äußeren konflikt wo es eben
eine aktive opposition passiert für den
helden und für die helden das sind eben
oft zu spiegel figuren oder spiel
die eben dann aktiv als open end zum
helden auftreten
zweiter punkt wäre so was wie ein
hindernis das eben zum für eben den
helden wieder auch zu seiner opposition
wird was aber passiv sein kann also wie
gesagt die objekt welt oder das wetter
oder irgendwie so es ist ziemlich
unspezifisch dann auch oder auf der
anderen seite neben diesen äußeren
konflikt auch im inneren konflikt also
dass es sich um das böse im inneren
einer figur drehen kann
das wäre dann ist ein interaktiver
konflikt der eben eine
auseinandersetzung mit dem bösen im
inneren einer figur nach sich zieht im
extremfall kann das natürlich zu sowas
wie perversität oder gewaltanwendungen
eben also nicht führen sondern das ist
eben das was dann da thematisiert werden
würde aber die folge ist oft dass so
eine innere konflikt dann auf einen
äußeren konflikte nach sich zieht im
feld
wesentlich ist also dass die
handlungsorientierte funktion also die
funktion auf der plot ebene das
konfliktpotenzial liefert damit eben
eine handlung überhaupt in gang kommt
das böse ist eben etwas was das ziel
potenzial eigentlich liefert im prinzip
haben wir ohne ohne das böse im film
keine handlung oftmals nicht also
wirklich wenige filme wo man wirklich
sagt das böse existiert eigentlich nicht
er das ist im prinzip ultimativ also
insofern es ist böse ein wesentlicher
bestandteil der formalen ordnung des
narrativen und somit filmischen text es
wird keine exzesse keine extra ordnung
irgendwie aufgebaut durch das böse
irgendwie eine eine ordnung verändert
sondern sie es ist wirklich bestandteil
dieses diese spots auf der nächsten
ebene der filmische code und das medium
ist es natürlich wichtig zu sagen dass
die darstellungs mittel selber nicht per
se böse sein können ja also
grundsätzlich farben schnitt musik
einsatz und so weiter die sind per se
nicht böse sondern die entwickeln eben
erst durch eine gewisse bedeutung
aufladung ihre böse ästhetik oder auch
eben ihren bösen effekt diese diese
funktionalisierung kann eben bei den
auditiven und visuellen codes über zwei
wege erfolgen
das eine ist dass es die tradierte
filmsprache ist also dinge die man
einfach kennt aus konvention weil es in
vielen filmen einfach so benutzt wird wo
eben das böse so eine gewisse kulturelle
übereinkunft ist wir wissen alle was
böse ist im film und das ist eben auch
wichtig wenn man sich da
unterschiedliche kulturelle kontexte
eben anschaut wenn man sich überlegt in
japanischen filmen also den jayhawks wie
man das nennt da ist es ganz typisch
dass es böse immer weiblich ist also das
gibt es bei uns wie gesagt auch aber es
ist nicht so klassisch wie im
japanischen horrorfilm wenn man sich zum
beispiel bei uns dem bekannten film der
im original anschaut da es eben auch
also das wäre so eine eine typische
personifikation des weiblichen bösen in
japanischen und da ist eben immer die
frage wie gut kennt man sich mit diesen
codes ausgeht so zu sagen da ein was
verloren weil man das eigentlich gar
nicht weiß
das ist ebenso diese kulturelle sache
zum bösen die man verstehen muss aber
das ist eben nicht nur so eine
traditionelle sache über konventionen
die wir schon kennen sondern auch jeder
film selber kann so eine gewisse motivik
auch entwickeln ja dass wir in einem
individuellen film oder einer reihe zu
gewisse kurz eben haben die daraus
entstehen und die man eben dann im
ganzen film narrativ da interpretieren
kann
und da ist es eben wichtig dass die die
funktion die das böse
eben auf dieser medium und code ebene
hat es ist die effekt funktion dieses
medium und der code eben haben kann und
die erfolg eben auch über diesen stark
der realität der realitätsbezug
das eine ist die visualisierung also
eigentlich die optik des bösen die
gewisse effekte erzeugen kann
also was man so typischerweise auch
kennt das wäre so ein colour kolding
dass wir eben wissen so wenn eine figur
kommt die dunkel angezogen ist wie
gargamel zum beispiel oder auch der dark
knight eigentlich hier in dem fall also
kann auch um die codiert seien in
neueren neueren filmen aber
grundsätzlich ist es schon mal so ein
marker da kommt jetzt was böses daher
deshalb nur so ein paar beispiele die
eben auf diese farbgebung abstellen aber
es gibt auch so was wie zum beispiel bei
bmo field in james bond das eben auch so
körperliche merkmale eben als marker
dienen um das böse im film zu zu
evozieren also hier profil mit dieser
name den ich weiß nicht ob man zieht
hier diese quer über die übers auge
drüber geht
wichtig ist eben das ist heutzutage mehr
und mehr aufgebrochen wird also wenn man
zum beispiel so was wie bei bedarf neid
auch da ist batman ja selber auch schon
schwarz aber auch wesentlich der hat ja
auch schon dieses böse in sicht erst
auch schon so eine so eine misch figur
aber das kann eben heute auch total
geändert werden dass eben böse film weiß
tragen oder so also mittlerweile ist es
auch nicht mehr so ganz klar
digitalisiert wichtig ist auch dass so
visuelle co2 perspektive und schnitt
hierzu film typisch sind auch oft selbst
sonne selbst eigentlich zur
gewaltanwendung werden
das eben auch was dem horrorfilm ganz
oft eingesetzt wird dass er eben einmal
durch so extreme close ups zum beispiel
so eine ganz unangenehme nähe empfinden
zu dem bösen wasser dargestellt wird
also dann ist es einmal das böse auf
dieser diesem film narrativ ebene auf
der anderen seite aber auch wie der
schnitt funktioniert dass man selber so
eine körperliche erfahrung des bösen
auch hat weisen
und intimität mit dem bösen hergestellt
wird genauso eben wenn man ebenso
schockartige schnitte hat zum beispiel
die die die sehr schnell und rasant
gehen oder eben schnell von einer
situation zu anderen die man eben
körperlich dann auch spüren kann ihm als
rezipient auditiv ist natürlich auch
möglich mit schadhaften geräusche und
natürlich auch die filmmusik also
filmmusik ist natürlich ganz
entscheidend für diese emotionen des
bösen
wenn man die filmmusik einfach weglässt
also da gibt es vom film space cowboys
wo man das gefühl hat die haben da
einfach die musik vergessen weil es
überhaupt keinen keine emotionale
wirkung erzeugt aber eben für den horror
und die gefahr die man empfinden soll es
eben diese filmmusik da ganz
entscheidend wo eben auch über
musikalische leitmotive auch ganz
typisch die böse figur auch immer dann
schon angedeutet wird also darth vader
der darf bei den kennt man ja auch so
und da weiß man schon die musik kommt
aha jetzt kommt er gleich wieder um die
ecke
ja so dass man eben genau die dinge wie
eben diese visuellen und auditiven kurs
dieser effekt funktion übernehmen um
dieses böse auch zu evozieren gut auf
der nächsten ebene ist auch schon das
letzte historische kontext und eben dann
also wir sind sozusagen auf der extra
sexuellen ebene mit produktionsseite und
rezipient rezeption seite ist es eben
wichtig dass es um diese wirkung
funktion geht also welche wirkung hat
das ganze dann auf entweder das
produktionsteam den kontext oder die
rezipienten als den ästhetischen effekt
auf der produktionsseite ist es jetzt
wichtig das ist das eben also oder auf
allen ebenen ist wichtig dass das ganze
so über das ästhetische produkt hinaus
weist also es ist eben nicht nur film
narrativ intern sondern da geht es
wirklich um diese funktionen die der
film eben auch in die gesellschaft in
die rezipienten und produzenten
hineinträgt was ich damit meine auf der
produktionsseite als beispiel wenn
schauspieler zu so einer art meta
bösewicht werden weil sie gewisse rolle
übernehmen wenn man so eine figur nimmt
wie hannibal lecter
also die kennt man ja schon recht gut
und sie hat auch schon diese böse aber
der witz ist dass anthony hopkins selber
dadurch auch so was sich also davon
beträgt sich eben auch auf den
schauspieler und es liegt also voll hat
auch die folge dass er da so ein
gewisses rollenfach belegte dass er
immer so psychopathische figurenspiel
die dann auch so leicht böse dann daher
kommen wenn man jetzt hat die vorsehung
zum beispiel wo er eigentlich waren
guten charakter also nicht gut aber halt
einen protagonisten spielt aber trotzdem
immer so mit dieser diesen bösen bösen
aura gespielt wird oder so was wie das
perfekte verbrechen wo er auch der
bösewicht ist das ist sowas das ihn ja
auch so in seiner person so ein bisschen
anhaftet auch auf der regisseur ebene
gibt so was natürlich das skandal
wirkungen des films sich eben auf die
produzenten übertragen
beispiel quentin tarantino den kennt ja
nun auch jeder deswegen weil er ja
solche filme hat wo man schon ganz genau
weiß da gibt es einfach um das böse us
blätter und das ganze zeug also von kill
bill über inglourious basterds zu django
unchained und natürlich auch pulp
fiction und so weiter und so weiter das
gehört ja alles damit dazu da bekommt
eben dann das böse auch so eine
vermarktungs funktion in diesem fall
eher dass eben diese filme sich auch
gerade dadurch gut verkaufen lassen weil
eben mit dieser stark der effekt wirkung
des bösen ja auch gespielt wird auf der
rezeption seite kann man auch so ein
bisschen drüber unterscheiden zwischen
seiner privat even einer perversen
dimension also privat ihf in dem sinne
dass ist es beziehe ich mich ein
bisschen auf jörgs buch auch diese
unterscheidung für dass es gute eben
immer noch als so eine überlegene
normative folie gilt das hat eben auch
effekte in dem zuschauerbereich um
entschuldigung wenn ich noch nicht und
zwar dass das böse eben auch für den
zuschauer so eine art kathartischen
effekt entwickeln kann und zwar einmal
im akku stil aristotelischen sinne und
einmal im lesbischen szene also
aristotelische wirklich in dem sinne
einer affekt befreien
also dadurch dass man sich gruseln und
angst hat dass man am ende auch so ein
bisschen entspannter aus der sache raus
geht ja aber eher dass das hängt auch
oft mit zu platz strukturen zusammen wo
es am ende so ein klassisches gutes gibt
es das böse dann auch besiegt das hat so
eine befriedigende wirkung und so einen
reinigenden effekt eben in bezug auf
diese effekte die man eben vorher
durchlebt hat das kann eben auch
entsprechend auf so einer kontext ebene
sein also zum historischen kontext jetzt
dass es auch einen gewissen sozialen
effekt haben kann dass man eben sich
auch in gewisser weise mit sozialen und
kulturellen ängsten über den film auch
auseinandersetzen kann damit und damit
so oft eine ganz gesellschaftlichen
ebene so ein kroatischer effekt entsteht
in bezug auf diese lässige übersetzung
von von aristoteles theorie im sinne
einer moralischen läuterung das wäre die
andere möglichkeit die entsteht also
dass wir so eine didaktische moralische
botschaft an den zuschauer haben
so nach dem motto das böse sollte man
nicht tun daher geht eben auch sehr
stark um diese aufdeckung von den
dunklen seiten eigener ordnungssysteme
indem man das böse als spiegelung des
aktuell eigenen imaginiert wenn man
jetzt als beispiel die insel nimmt das
da geht es ja darum dass klar dass die
gesellschaft in ein paar jahren in der
zukunft klone klone züchtet deren organe
dafür benutzt werden anderen menschen
das leben zu retten ja die werden dann
einfach umgebracht die organe werden
genommen
damit ihnen die richtigen menschen dann
auch überleben können
und nachdem jack lohnen auch bei uns in
unserer gesellschaft gar nicht mal so
weit entfernt ist ja ist es eben genau
die sache wo eben diese kulturellen
gesellschaftlichen diskurse eben
aufgegriffen werden und durchgespielt
werden und da eben auch so eine
gesellschaftskritik dann entsteht als
gegenentwurf natürlich auch so eine
moralische identitätsstiftung unter den
zuschauern wenn man eben gerade diese
klassischen böse böse szenarien oder
böse gegenentwürfe darstellt die eben
auch mit unserer kultur was zu tun haben
wie zum beispiel nazis
die eben immer auch als das böse
etabliert werden und dargestellt werden
in filmen und eben dadurch auch diese
die auseinandersetzung mit dem thema
eben dann auch durchgeführt wird und
dadurch eben dann auch dieser moralische
effekt erzeugt werden soll
weiterer punkt auf dieser privat even
ebenen dimension also dass das gute
sozusagen immer noch das überlegene ist
wäre auch so eine skandalisierung im
film also dass das ganze eben auch so
ein gewisse aufmerksamkeit und
kommerziellen erfolg hat was aber auch
zu seiner ablehnung und zensur führen
kann ja wenn man eben über das böse
spricht im film da so eine diskussion im
leben entsteht auch inwiefern ethik und
ästhetik dann wieder zusammen hängen was
darf man im film eigentlich überhaupt
noch machen
ist es überhaupt in ordnung das böse so
und so im film darzustellen oder müssen
wir darauf schauen wo die grenze ist was
die ästhetik eigentlich noch darf auf
dieser perkussiven dimension indem eben
das böse er als eine andere science form
dargestellt wird aber eben nicht dem
guten unterlegen ist sondern eben schon
auch als so ein eigenes ding war was
auch so eine gewisse ästhetik haben kann
kann es natürlich wieder andere effekte
auf den zuschauer auswirken
das einzige wäre natürlich so eine art
befriedigung der lust am gruseln und am
grauenhaften weil neben ja auch hier die
freiheit besteht das böse mal auf einem
sicheren terra durchzuspielen
also man bekommt keine negativen folgen
ab wenn man das böse empfehlen sich
anschaut und sich da kusel und es
vielleicht auch irgendwie toll findet er
also so ein ästhetischer genuss ist eben
im film möglich weil das böse eben auch
da einen sicheren rahmen hat das hat
natürlich viel mit neugier
sensationslust und voyeurismus zu tun
und die folge ist eben da auch oder auch
die funktion dass es ebenso eine
ästhetisierung des bösen eben haben kann
ja das ist dass es so eine faszination
bekommt wo man sich auch irgendwie
vielleicht damit identifizieren kann mit
diesen abgründen also nach dem motto das
böse ist auch irgendwie sexy ja also das
habe ich oft mal wenn man
studenten bei harry potter rede dass die
eben alle auch professor snape total
sexy finden also das ist eben auch was
was da so ein bisschen mehr rein spielt
kann natürlich auch ohne intendierte
wird effekte haben auf die zuschauer
wenn man darüber redet dass das ganze
auch so eine bewusstmachung der freiheit
zum bösen sein kann
also da wäre man klassisch bei dieser
ego shooter debatte ob eben wenn wir das
böse uns im film anschauen eben dadurch
auch selber besser werden also das eben
wenn man sich oder wie ballerspiele wenn
man das eben dann auch noch selber tut
dass das eben auch negative effekte
haben kann und dass dadurch ebenso ein
effekt der normalisierung eintritt lance
ward redet da eben von der männer die
auf ivo die dadurch etabliert wird dass
sie eben den ästhetischen produkten
immer so durchgespielt wird gut
zusammenfassen kann ich sagen dass eben
das film das böse im film sehr breit
angelegt ist aber das entscheidende ist
eben für mich dass das böse im film eben
nur über diese funktionalität eigentlich
relevant wird
und da ist es aber dann auch
kategorisiert bar über diese einzelnen
funktionen also wenn wir einmal von
dieser handlungs funktion sprechen die
auf der ebene des filmarchivs passiert
das zweite die effekt funktion auf der
ebene des mediums und des codes und das
dritte die wirkung ctio noch den ebenen
des kontextes der produktion und der
rezeption des werden sozusagen die drei
wichtigen funktionen die das böse
übernehmen kann
zwei wichtige punkte die ich jetzt
versucht habe herauszuarbeiten dass eben
das böse im film durch eine zuschreibung
entsteht da sind wir wieder beim diskurs
des bösen das eben die frage ist wer
schreibt den bösen was wann wem zu und
das zweite das anstatt das böse im film
etwas ist was nicht sein darf muss es
sogar sein dass ein club überhaupt erst
in gang kommt also ohne das böse haben
wir eigentlich kein archiv meiner
ansicht nach und dadurch ist eben das
böse im film in der ästhetischen diskurs
unglaublich produktiv und
dementsprechend ist es eben auch genre
epochen und handlungs und
abhängig es ist eben für die
filmästhetik ultimativ und somit film
ästhetisch inhärent meiner meinung nach
als abschließen der beobachtung würde
ich noch anfügen dass die aktuell in der
aktuellen filmlandschaft eben auch eine
entwicklung zu einer größeren vielfalt
und komplexität des bösen auch
wahrnehmbar ist wir haben eben auf der
einen seite diese klassischen binären
positionen die aufgebaut werden als so
was wie wo lord voldemort als den bösen
schlechthin
wir haben aber auch ganz viele
unvorhersehbare formen des bösen im film
heutzutage und dadurch ist auch in
gewisser weise ein kritischer umgang mit
dem bösen möglich weil das böse weniger
abstrakt und oberflächlich erscheint und
das hat natürlich zur folge dass eine
kritische reflexion auch möglich wird
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit